there are days that define your story  beyond your life like the day they  arrived carnal thank you banks language  is the first weapon drawn in a conflict  that's quite a greeting yeah well you  wrote it you are on the top everyone's  on this one close to translations I  already won what do they want where are  you from  not everyone is wired for what you're  about to do so where they look like  you'll see soon enough every 18 Ellis  door opens up that's what we go  it's time  what happens now arrived bill operating  defendant at this room i endangered the  lives of all those passengers I got an  a320 diving for the rivers everything  you could hope was more than enough ones  a last drink that my soul burn any